admiral brett burrar former coronavirus
white house task force member and former
hhs assistant secretary for health how
are you doing sir
uh good day to you great cdc says no to
the mask now the pediatrician's group's
coming out and saying
two-year-olds have to wear them in the
classroom is that necessary
so i still firmly agree with the cdc
that if you are fully vaccinated we know
vaccines are highly effective
and they're safe you are protected if
you're fully vaccinated
you should not need to wear a mask you
should feel safe and i believe that is
correct guidance and should continue
in terms of the american academy of
pediatrics their report yesterday one
thing they did say that i fully agree
with
is that it is imperative for all
children to get back to school in person
that was in bold in their statement and
i agree with it aside from that
that statement was more about social
change and social policy
and it was very light on the science i
completely disagree
that children over 12 who are vaccinated
should wear a mask
and i think there is a strong argument
that children
under 12 should not wear a mask or at
least that should be
part of a debate and not just assumed
abroad i think the confusion for a lot
of parents when they
have the american pediatrics the academy
of pediatrics making this statement
suggesting such that kids as as young as
two should be wearing masks and then
school-aged kids kindergarten even
should be wearing masks
why only look at one aspect
of this obviously the spread of the
possible virus
but why isn't there any concern about
the lost learning the lost productivity
for kids the lost socialization when
they don't see each other's faces
why isn't that of equal concern because
this is
this is these are our kids this is our
future
i i completely agree with you we know
and there's increasing evidence
that children are at incredibly low
risks
of death and it is even arguable that
any normal
children or significant numbers have
died a new report out of the united
kingdom
showed that only 25 people under age 18
died of covet in the entire last year
and half of those
were chronically ill like on respirators
and feeding tubes so we need to debate
that
the aap even cites the wh if we listen
to the who the children will be safe
what they cite from the who says
children under five
should not wear a mask at all because
it's going to inhibit their social
development
and and you shouldn't do it and between
6 and 11
only under very specific high-risk
circumstances so
even the material that the aap cites is
contrary to their recommendation
i can understand why people are are
confused jerome adams former surgeon
general you look
worked very closely with him on the task
force he came out with quite a statement
this week here it is he said
he said last year tony fauci and i
famously prematurely
and wrongly advised against masks
i felt it was the best call at the time
but now regret it
instead of vaccinate or mask it the
emerging data suggests cdc should be
advising to vaccine
and mask it in areas with upwards arrow
cases and positivity
until we see numbers going back down
again cdc was well intended but the
message was misinterpreted premature
and wrong let's fix it joe you've got
that out there
then here was fauci on monday of this
week roll this this is call for number
three guys
watch the cdc recommendations
may be at variance with that but in in
in
every respect the cdc always leaves open
the flexibility at the part of local
agencies local enterprises local cities
and states
to make a judgment call based on the
situation on the ground
i think that's reasonable thing to do he
talked about flexibilities
recommendations on the ground with this
new delta variant what
what's important about knowing
hospitalization rates and death rates
about the variant when you've already
gotten the vaccine
many of us so let me
make it clear a few points that everyone
needs to understand
if you are fully vaccinated you are not
100
percent protected but you're well over
90 to 95 percent protected
even against delta so it is a good
recommendation that if you're fully
vaccinated
you do not need to wear a mask if you
are unvaccinated the delta variant
is very contagious 60 70 maybe a hundred
percent more contagious than the
baseline variance
so if you're unvaccinated you are you
are susceptible and you need to wear a
mask
very very important i do not believe
it's important unless you're at an
uh an age group over 85 or you have
underlying conditions
that if you're vaccinated to wear a mask
as well it's certainly your option
my 88 year old mother if she's gone in
public she's fully vaccinated
we talk about wearing masks to give her
extra protection but aside from those
groups you should be good
if you could in a couple words because
we've got to leave it there admiral
where are we in this we kind of felt
like we were living in this almost in a
post-pandemic world
and now there's just so many more fears
where are we with this
um we're at a very you know delicate
and potentially dangerous point because
the delta variant will spread among
those who are unvaccinated
there is no question about that our
hospitals are in a very different
situation you know we have treatments we
have ppe we have lots of hospital
capacity
but i do urge people please get
vaccinated it will protect you against
all the variants and we can put this
thing in our history
but we're still in the middle of the
fight and people need to take it
wow okay sir thank you come on back soon
brett gerard thank you admiral nice to
see you thanks admiral
thank you hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary
any great news bites any great
interviews coming your way on fox you
can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now